en tout de suite avec l'autre
blanchemaison bonjour à vous vous êtes
expert en relations internationales on
connaît bien ici je exit les sanctions
américaines la corde entre berlin et
moscou est ce que marque la fin de
tensions géopolitiques de longue date
est ce que c'est un accord qui est le
fruit d'un succès diplomatique de joe
biden le chemin que c'est plutôt un
succès diplomatique pour madame merkel
en ce qui concerne jour baydan ça montre
sa sa capacité à négocier son savoir
faire et puis aussi son pragmatisme
alors pragmatique car l'évidence c'est
tout le contraire d'un doctrinaire et il
est si me l'a montré avec la lumière
putty hill 16 juillet dès le 7 juin
dernier à genève 16 juin dernier à
genève
il a montré qu'il savait faire la part
des choses prince et des lignes rouges
mais progresser sur les sujets sur
lesquels cela était possible et en
levant les sanctions sur les entreprises
qui est poursuivre l'achèvement de leur
stream 2 en effet il fait plaisir à
madame merkel qui devait beaucoup à ce
dossier et en même temps au moment où la
levée des sanctions cdh et à quelques
jours de la rencontre du 16 juin à
genève par conséquent il crée des
conditions positives pour cette
rencontre avec le président poutine
simplement il ya des conditions comme
cela a toujours été dit c'est à dire que
ceci ne doit pas amoindrir les recettes
de transit que touche le cren lorsque le
gaz russe traverse dans des gazoducs qui
traversent l'ukraine ce pays alors même
si les deux grands pays de l'accord sont
l'allemagne et la russie
que peuvent gagner les autres pays
européen oui je pense que c'est
favorable d'abord à l'ensemble de
l'union européenne puisque cela crée des
infrastructures fixes entre la russie et
les pays de l'union européenne en
passant par l'allemagne et que ces
infrastructures fixes fournissent du gaz
par conséquent c'est une garantie
d'approvisionnement
je pense aussi que c'est favorable à la
conception d'une grande europe par
ailleurs d'une europe de lisbonne à
vladivostok comme on dit puisque ça
montre la complémentarité qu'il y a
entre les ressources naturelles que l'on
trouve en russie est le plus grand
marché de consommation au monde qu'est
l'union européenne alors justement pour
l'ukraine et la pologne deux pays qui
campent sur leur position est ce que la
province de maintenir des ressources
pour l'ukraine est suffisante
oui à la pause qui est forcé de
l'ukraine l'ukraine à une position assez
politique c'est à dire que depuis le
début depuis qu'il a élu monsieur et
l'ins qui a repris les positions
antérieures en déclarant son hostilité à
ce projet north stream 2 il a répété à
plusieurs reprises et il le répète à
chaque fois qu'il rencontre des
occidentaux et le redira à monsieur jobs
à edel lorsqu'il le reverra la position
de repli de l'ukraine c'est qu'au moins
on lui garantissent les recettes qu'il
touche lorsque le gaz russe transitent
par les vieux gazoduc qui traverse ce
pays
on voit bien que cela veut dire qu'il
faudrait un accord à long terme entre la
russie et l'ukraine et que pour le
moment et l'irak
qui dure jusqu'en 2024 et qui fournit
cette garantie jusqu'en 2024
effectivement on voit bien que monsieur
lavrov jouent avec l'idée que peut-être
pour la suite il faudrait un concours
extérieur de l'allemagne l'union
européenne pour cette garantie de
recettes fourni à l'ukraine
on n'en est pas là et en tout cas pour
ce qui est de la pologne la pologne n'a
pas grand chose à dire dans cette
affaire puisqu'elle n'est pas
directement concernée elle est concernée
naturellement par l'attitude globale de
l'union européenne vis-à-vis de la
russie
elle l'a montré d'adhérents en
s'opposant à la reprise du dialogue
lors du dernier conseil européen là je
crois qu'il va falloir à un moment donné
que varsovie faire un arbitrage entre
son cousinage avec le gouvernement
hongrois sur un certain nombre de sujets
sur les valeurs traditionnelles sur un
certain nombre de sujets qui d'ailleurs
pose problème à bruxelles
et puis cette opposition à la russie que
ne partage pas du tout monsieur hamad
très rapidement claude blanchemaison les
conséquences sur globalement sur les
relations entre la russie et l'europe
toute entière est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à une certaine détente
oui je pense que c'est en tout cas
d'éléments positifs ça ne suffira pas il
faut certainement reprendre pour
améliorer sensiblement ses relations la
proposition qui a été faite par la
chancelière allemande lors du dernier
conseil européen reprises par le
président français 2
tenir à nouveau une réunion entre eux au
sommet entre l'union européenne et la
russie
ces réunions avaient lieu tous les six
mois jusqu'au début 2014
cela fait donc plus de sept ans
maintenant il n'ya pas une réunion de ce
genre et ces réunions n'ont pas pour
objet de dire qu'on est d'accord sur
tout elles ont pour objet de se dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont deux tracés
des lignes rouges sur ce qui est
inacceptable
d'un côté ou de l'autre et puis
d'identifier les sujets de coopération
possible c'est très exactement la
méthode qu'a adoptée joe biden à genève
le 16 juin
merci à vous blanche maison pour tous de
cette précision je rappelle que cet
expert en relations internationales